Do you destroy the world how
many dead eyes can you look into
before you die inside yourself
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new justice league snyder cut trailer video
zack snyder was also revealing some really big
details about plans that he had to actually
put ryan reynolds green lantern in the movie
so i'll explain what was going on with that
because that's actually a pretty big deal we
actually thought that it was a joke a while ago
but turns out he seriously actually talked to ryan
reynolds about putting him in the movie if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos the movie's coming this week so i'll be
doing a bunch more videos for it later through the
rest of the week what i'll do is i'll talk about
the green lantern stuff first because that's such
a huge deal then i'll talk about this new footage
because darkseid is going around killing all the
different justice league members and you have the
joker narrating it all but just a little while ago
ryan reynolds was joking because of st patrick's
day you know what i'm going to do i'm actually
going to drink a whole bunch of the gin that i
own he owns a gin company called aviation gin and
watch the green lantern movie for the first time
because turns out he's never actually watched
the theatrical cut of the green lantern film
i probably wouldn't have wanted to watch it too if
i had been him but you remember all the talk about
him supposedly being in the movie last year there
was this big rumor that was going around and then
ryan reynolds came out and said you know what
i'm not in the film i'm not going to be playing
hawkman in the black adam film but i'm really
excited to see it vengeance as a joke he posted a
video to his twitter that he was calling the green
lantern ryan reynolds cup where he did like this
funny parody super cut of green lantern with a
bunch of deadpool 2 footage he photoshopped tom
cruise's face onto his face like tom cruise was
in his version of the green lantern film then he
edited his green lantern a version of himself into
the justice league theatrical cut so everyone kind
of took that to mean that he wasn't going to be in
the film like okay this rumor turned out to not be
a thing but just this past day zack snyder came
out and explained that he was actually originally
supposed to be in the movie he had this big idea
to swap ryan reynolds green lantern into the
snyder cut this is the clip of him talking about
that there was another idea i had for the green
lantern that wasn't ryan and so i thought that
if we had gone down this path of green lantern
i would have had to have ryan as the additional
lantern got it so it could have been maybe he
would have been there as well as other lanterns as
well as another lantern that would have been but
that's another story so what he's saying there is
that he was deciding on what to add to the movie
when they decided that they were actually going
to do the snyder cut and they green lit it there
were a bunch of things that he added to the snyder
cut that originally were not supposed to be in his
theatrical cut like new stuff that he only just
thought of when they started working on the snyder
cut best example of that is the jared leto joker
scenes there was never going to be any joker in
zack snyder's original version of the theatrical
cut but because years later we'd never gotten to
see ben affleck's batman share any scenes with
his version of the joker jared leto's joker zack
snyder said that he wanted to pay that off but the
scene that he's talking about for ryan reynolds
green lantern that would have been in the snyder
cut he would have been the other green lantern in
a very particular scene what he's talking about is
that he would have replaced another green lantern
that was already there with ryan reynolds green
lantern like photoshop you out photoshop ryan
reynolds in and i believe the scene that he was
talking about was supposed to happen at the end
of the movie like a post credit scene or an end
credit scene and two green lanterns were coming
to visit batman at his lake house originally
i believe they were supposed to be killwog in
tomar ray and they would have warned him about
darkseid the forces of apocalypse and they would
have started developing a plan for the green
lantern corps to come help them out team up with
the justice league and then they would have paid
that off in the justice league sequels this is
the actual storyboard from i think it was justice
league 3 where the full green lantern corps rolls
in like the cavalry with every lantern you've
ever heard of to help them finally just kick
dark side off the planet zack snyder also talked
about the justice league sequels too he actually
confirmed one of my theories that i talked about
in an earlier video so i'll explain that later
in the video so had ryan reynolds actually wound
up being in the movie it would have been him and
killwog's green lanterns coming to visit batman
at the end of the film but i believe what happened
with the ryan reynolds green lantern stuff is
that either ryan reynolds wasn't available when
they needed him to do this or he just politely
declined because he didn't actually want to play
green lantern again and i believe what wound
up happening after that is zack snyder changed
this green lantern ending scene with killwog and
tomar ray to the martian manhunter scene that was
actually in the last big trailer the scene you
see here where it looks like superman's coming
to batman's lake house with the sunlight behind
him i believe that's actually supposed to be
martian manhunter at the end of the movie as for
the other martian manhunter stuff in the film i
believe has also since been confirmed that in the
previous scene here of martha wayne where her eyes
are glowing red it's really supposed to be martian
manhunter or martha manhunter disguising himself
so that he can go check on either superman or lois
lane and eventually he explains to them through
the course of the film how he's been living
on earth this whole time for a long time just
watching humans and trying to influence things
in a positive direction from behind the scenes by
being this general stanwick persona the whole time
like you go back to the man of steel film so this
is martian manhunter he's been living as stan wick
for a long long time just rising through the ranks
of the military into a position of great authority
i believe the idea is that he just didn't trust
humans to fully reveal himself as an alien with
superpowers and it was the coming of superman in
the man of steel movie in batman v superman that
really turned him around on that like there was
that line of dialogue in one of the other trailers
where he talks about how it's time for him to step
out of the shadows because he cares about humanity
so much at this point zack snyder showed off
storyboards with his character the go-back years
like really old storyboards so i'm assuming that
means he always planned on the martian manhunter
twist in his version of the theatrical cut when
they were still going to be making the sequels
in martian manhunter would have become a bigger
character during the sequels but just talking
about the new footage of darkseid going around
killing all the justice league members obviously
big wtf twist in this trailer all the joker's
narration is coming during the nightmare scene
because that's when his scenes take place it's
kind of like a whole nightmare timeline trailer
in fact with all the footage of darkseid going
around killing the different members in this
post-apocalyptic future speaking of joker too zack
snyder revealed that it was jared leto himself
who ad-libbed though we live in a society line
for those of you who are wondering where that line
came from in that previous trailer but the joker's
first line about violence in this new trailer gets
cut off a little mid-sentence but then he asks do
you destroy the world as he goes around killing
different members how many dead eyes can you
look into before you die on the inside yourself
so it sounds like he's talking to batman during
the speech as they're cutting it with the footage
of the different league members but it's aquaman
that's the first to go in atlantis this is from
that same scene of dark side with the omega beams
that i was talking about a couple days ago so it
seems like that's how he's able to get aquaman
like he incapacitates him with the omega beams
then spears him with his mother's trident everyone
press f to pay respects to the justice league this
is now confirmed to be wonder woman's funeral pyre
and hippolyta the other amazons are burning her
body after darkseid kills her in some other scene
then when joker is talking about dying on the
inside you see the scene of him behind superman
like he puts his hand on superman's shoulder while
superman is crying cradling someone's burned body
in what looks like a version of the bat cave
this is probably supposed to be the moment where
darkseid is able to turn superman evil using the
anti-life equation in the whole thing that flash
time traveled back to warn batman about during the
events of batman be superman you notice flash is
even wearing the same future time travel suit in
this other nightmare footage the reports from a
couple years ago said that originally what the
idea was is that darkseid is going to come kill
lois lane instead of trying to directly just kill
superman because he wanted to use superman's power
to help conquer the earth but in order to do that
because superman was so powerful he had to break
him emotionally first so that he loses all hope
like what does the s stand for it stands for hope
big man of steel callback in the way that darkseid
was going to do that was to kill lois lane
kill the thing that he cared about most leading
to the events of this nightmare scene where batman
watches as he comes to kill him on darkseid's
orders then in the justice league sequels we were
going to see the flash in the future develop the
time travel plan with cyborg the other surviving
justice league members like batman then in justice
league 2 justice league 3 they start the new
timeline where batman is able to save lois lane
in the past so that superman never falls to dark
side's influence and that gives them the edge they
need to defeat him with the help of eventually the
green lantern corps rolling in but the big theory
that i posted on my twitter the other day zack
snyder actually confirmed and it was all about the
justice league sequels so he said openly that the
studio warner brothers in a t don't seem like they
have any interest in actually turning those into
real movies you know who knows never say never
it's always possible they could change their
minds down the road but initially my thought was
because they spent so much time developing this
story and jim lee himself one of the best comic
book artists of all time had spent so much time
drawing all these storyboards and mapping the
story out with zack snyder why don't they just
turn it into a big comic book series so you still
get the story it's just in a different format
zack snyder explained that originally he and jim
lee were going to do that they were actually going
to do the sequels as a big big comic book series
like a really long running comic book series
he also said he was going to pay off the whole
batman dead robin in joker storyline in a separate
comic book probably with jim lee as well but what
ended up happening is a couple years ago when they
were going to start doing that project is that the
att buyout happened like they basically bought out
time warner and while that was happening whatever
executives at at t basically canceled that project
he said now he's actually hopeful that at some
point they'll get to eventually do that so it does
sound like even if we don't get to see them make
those justice league sequels you'll still get to
see that story play out in a big comic book but
because we know what that story is like we have
all those story boards i'll actually do a separate
video about that sometime later this week or next
week after i do some more justice league snyder
cup videos when people have a chance to actually
watch the movie i believe the movie is supposed to
be dropping midnight tonight on hbo max at least
by midnight it could be dropping a little bit
earlier my first video for that will post thursday
morning and then my falcon and winter soldier
episode 1 video will post friday and then after
that i'll just try to get through all my justice
league snyder cut in other falcon and winter
soldier videos so there's a lot of really cool
stuff coming from all over the place in the next
week or so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of those videos
while you wait for everything click here for
that brand new falcon winter soldier episode
1 trailer video and click here for that
brand new godzilla vs kong trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!